في اليوم الساس لمعارك قطاع غزه لا تزال
المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على ضرب العمق
الاسرائلي اذا اعلنت كتاب القسام اليوم
انها ضربت تل ابيب بعده صواريخ وبشقه
صاروخيه قيل في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
انها من اكبر الرشقات الصاروخيه التي ضربت
هذه المنطقه بالاضافه ايضا الى قصف مناطق
عسقلان واسدود في المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه ليتواصل القصف الفلسطيني على
مناطقه اسرائيليه تبعد في تل ابيب تبعد
حوالي 70 م عن قطاع غزه في اليوم الس 76
للمعارك في القطاع ولكن هذه ليست الضربات
الوحيده التي قامت بها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
وفق اعلانات كتائب القسام والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه فان محاور القتال البري في
مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه شهدت التحاما
مباشرا بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمقاومين الفلسطينيين ولكن قبل ذلك كانت
الضربات الجويه الاسرائيليه والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه قد شملت كل مناطق قطاع غزه من
اقصى مناطق شمال قطاع غزه الى مدينه رفح
في المنطقه الجنوبيه والتركيز بطبيعه
الحال على مناطق شمال غزه ومدينه غزه وعلى
مناطق خانيونس ولكن تبقى العمليه البريه
او الضغط البري والتوغل البري هو الذي
يشهد اكبر قدر ممكن من الالتحام والخسائر
في صفوف الجنود الاسرائيليين اذا ما ذهبنا
مباشره الى المناط
الشماليه من قطاع غزه فنحن نتحدث عن
نقطتين اساسيتين او محورين اساسيين
ذكرتهما كتائب القسام خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه بانها اوقعت عددا من
الاصابات بين قتيل وجريح في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي المنطقه الاولى هي منطقه
اليرموك في هذه المنطقه هذه بلده هذه
البلده القديمه في مدينه غزه حي الدرج
وهذا هو حي اليرموك هذا ملعب اليرموك الذي
نتحدث عنه دائما هذا ملعب فلسطين و وهذا
مسجد فلسطين في هذه النقطه هذا المسجد تم
تدمير هذه المنطقه بشكل كامل وفق اعلانات
وسائل الاعلام ونشطاء فلسطينيين وصحفيين
فلسطينيين بان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قصف
هذه المنطقه ودمر مسجد فلسطين والمنطقه
المحيطه فيها ولكن في منطقه اليرموك هذه
منطقه اليرموك قالت كتائب القسام بانها
استهدفت مبنى تحصن فيه جنود اسرائيليون في
منطقه اليرموك وقتلت سته جنود اسرائيليين
بشكل مباشر حيث قالت الكتائب لانها اجهزت
على سته جنود اسرائيليين كانوا يتحصنون في
منطقه اليرموك من المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه او من البلده
القديمه من مدينه غزه هذه المنطقه ليست
الوحيده التي كانت قد شهدت مواجهه مباشره
والتحام مباشر بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وجنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن
المنطقه الشماليه ايضا من مدينه غزه شهدت
قتالا عنيفا وتحديدا المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه ونتحدث عن منطقه
التوام هذه منطقه التوام في التي نشاهدها
على الخريطه والتي كانت قد توغلت فيها
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في الاسابيع
الاولى للتوغل البري الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه تقول كتائب القسام اليوم بانها قتلت
في منطقه توام 11 جنديا اسرائيليا بعد
تفجير عبوه شواذ في القوه الراجله وبعد
ذلك قدمت قوه اخرى مكونه من ثمانيه جنود
وقالت الكتائب بانها ايضا ضربت هذه القوه
المسانده لتكون مجمل القتلى الاسرائيليين
حتى هذه اللحظه وفق اعلان كتائب القسام
بطبيعه الحاله خلال الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
يتجاوز رقم 17 جنيه بين التوام وبين منطقه
اليرموك بالاضافه الى رقم ثمانيه الرقم
القوه المسانده للقوه التي تم تفجير فيها
في منطقه توام لا يعلم مصير هؤلاء ان
كانوا قتلوا بشكل كامل ام ان بينهم قتيل
وجريح ولكن تتحدث عن 17 جنديا اسرائيليا
قتلوا في منطقتي التوام واليرموك بقي ان
نشير لاعلان كتاب القسام على اللسان
الناطق باسمها ابو عبيده اليوم بانه تم
تفجير 720 اليه عسكريه اسرائليه منذ بدء
الغزو البري لقطاع غزه ا نتحدث اذا ما
حسبنا بالارقام فنحن نتحدث عن نهايه
اكتوبر تقريبا حتى اليوم نتحدث عن 720 ال
هذا يعني اننا نتحدث عن تقريبا 14 ليه
اسرائيليه تم تفجيرها وتدميرها بشكل شبه
كامل او تدميرا جزئيا او كليا في محاور
القتال في قطاع غزه بقي ان اشير سريعا الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه تقول سرايا القدس بانها
استهدفت بقذائف الهاون تحش تت القوات
الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
الفلسطينيه مع قصف شديد وعنيف تنفذه
المدفعيه والطيران الاسرائيلي لكل مناطق
قطاع غزه وقصف فلسطيني للعمق الاسرائيلي
يصل الى تل ابيب في اليوم الس 76 لهذه
الحرب المتواصله على قطاع غزه